well good morning all the white house
coronavirus task force met today here at
the Department of Education part of our
ongoing effort to focus on a mission to
save lives meet the needs of our state's
our health care workers to protect the
vulnerable and to safely reopen America
and reopen America's schools as you will
hear today from Admiral Brett gerar at
this point we have tested more than 39
million Americans among those more than
3 million Americans have tested positive
and more than 1.3 million Americans have
recovered sadly more than 133,000
Americans have lost their lives and our
sympathies are with all of the impacted
families and while we mourn with those
who mourn because of what the American
people have done because the
extraordinary work of our health care
workers around the country we are
encouraged that the average fatality
rate continues to be low and steady and
it days earlier this week was actually
90 percent lower then at the height of
this pandemic again it's a credit to the
sacrifices the American people have made
that the extraordinary work that our
health care workers are doing and and we
pledge this task force working in
partnership with governor's all across
the country is going to continue to work
our hearts out 24 hours a day to
continue to keep our losses low in just
a few moments dr. deborah birx
will outline the data that we're seeing
around the country we're tracking
literally state-by-state county by
county but as she will describe in a
moment we're actually seeing early
indications of a
of positive testing flattening in
Arizona and Florida and Texas governor's
in each of those states have taken
strong steps to flatten the curve and
again as dr. Burks will describe we're
beginning to see early indications that
positivity is flattening and in Arizona
and Florida we are beginning to see
declining numbers of emergency room
visits as well
we believe that take away from this for
every American particularly in those
states that are impacted is just keep
doing what you're doing
because we're starting to see the first
indications that as we were able to do
in the Northeast as we were able to do
in New Orleans in Louisiana and Michigan
and other places around the country
we're putting into practice those
mitigation efforts and we're beginning
to see indications that they are having
a good effect we are focused on the
states where more than half of the new
cases have arisen Texas Arizona Florida
and California and have received
encouraging reports even through this
morning strong supplies of PPE and
hospitals Hospital capacity remains
strong the one need that we did hear
from governor's across the region is for
personnel and over the last week working
through FEMA the Department of Defense
and HHS we've been processing a request
to deploy over a thousand and seventy
doctors and nurses and medical personnel
at this point roughly 525 doctors and
nurses are on the ground in Arizona
California and Texas and we're
processing a request from Florida for an
additional amount we've made it very
clear as as we you'll recall we deployed
at the president's Direction active duty
military medical personnel to New York
to New Jersey to Connecticut to Michigan
to Louisiana and we're in the process of
doing that again just to make sure that
that those dedicated doctors and nurses
and health care workers have the relief
that they need as we see cases rising in
various communities across the Sunbelt
and will continue to work that we had a
conference call yesterday with the
nation's governor's we are in the
process of continuing to sound every
week
a detailed county by county summaries
analysis and recommendations to
governor's that are being that are being
implemented and well received
we also are issuing renewed guidance on
preservation and reuse of PPE again what
we're hearing and not just speaking to
governor's but talking directly to
hospitals is that frankly because of the
historic effort that President Trump
implemented to spin up hundreds of
millions of supplies of gloves and and
masks and face shields and as well as
the construction of ventilators we now
have fifty nine thousand ventilators in
our supplies PPE we here remains very
strong but we're encouraging healthcare
workers to begin now to use some of the
best practices that we learned in other
parts of the country to to preserve and
to reuse the PPE supplies so our focus
is to make sure our states have
everything they need when they need it
and we're working closely with all the
governor's to make that a reality but
what brings us to the Department of
Education is as we as we see to the
needs of our state's and we focus on the
health care of the American people we're
working to reopen America and reopen
America schools yesterday president
Trump convened a summit of Education
leaders and health officials at the
White House and as the president made
clear yesterday it's time it's time for
us to get our kids back to school and
when the summit yesterday gave us an
opportunity to to outline and to learn
what we might be able to do that in just
a few moments I'm going to ask secretary
DeVos to talk about the approach the
Department of Education is taking to
assisting local communities and stay
in bringing their schools back online
and also we hear from dr. Bob Redfield
who has been literally since early in
this pandemic providing guidance to
schools and will be issuing additional
guidance next week I wouldn't want to
pass the opportunity though not just as
vice president but as as someone who's
been married to a schoolteacher now for
35 years just to say to say thank you to
all the teachers out there from early in
this pandemic and teachers learned how
to do the distance teaching and did a
remarkable job often times having to
care for their own families and make
sure their own children's studies were
happening so to all of our America's
teachers we say thank you
we also want to say thank you to the
parents the parents who had to step in
and become educators for all of their
kids it's really been remarkable when
you see what our kids have been able to
accomplish during this difficult time
but what we heard again yesterday from
education officials and and what we
heard from the American Academy of
Pediatrics it's absolutely essential
that we get our kids back into classroom
for in-person learning we can't let our
kids fall behind academically but it's
important that the American people
remember that that for children that
that have mental health issues for
special needs children for nutrition for
children in in communities facing
persistent poverty the school is the
place where they receive all those
services and so this is not just simply
about making sure our kids are learning
and they're advancing academically but
but but for their mental health for
their well-being for their physical
health for nutrition we got to get our
kids back to school and as as you heard
the president yesterday and even again
this morning we're absolutely determined
to work in partnership with our states
to give the guidance for stay
and communities to be able to safely
reopen our schools the CDC will be
issuing new guidance next week part of a
five-part a series of recommendations
that will give all new tools to our
schools but what dr. Redfield made clear
yesterday I'm sure he'll make clear
again today is we're here to help
we don't want federal guidance to be a
substitute for state and local laws and
rules and guidance we we're here to
assist with the shared objective that I
think is shared by every parent in
America which is we want to get our kids
back I'm going to get them back in the
classroom I want to get our teachers
back in the front of those classrooms we
got to get our kids learning in person
once again as Congress is still in
recess but we'll gather again soon we
already earn discussions about
additional potential support although we
were able to remind governor's at
thirteen point three billion dollars is
available in the cares Act of four
states to be able to assist them as they
roll out and restart schools across the
country at the present moment we learned
yesterday that only 1.5 percent of those
funds has been drawn down by States and
we encouraged governor's to take
advantage of that our objectives as I
said are to save lives meet the needs of
our state's and their health care
workers protect the most vulnerable and
safely reopen America and safely reopen
our schools and the good news is we are
we are reopening America the jobs report
less Thursday spoke for itself nearly 5
million jobs created and I can tell you
evidence all around the country is that
the American people are finding a way to
do their part to put the health of their
neighbors first even while we all find a
way to get back to work to worship and
to school and we all have a role to play
to slow the spread to protect the most
vulnerable and to safely reopen our
country and our schools and so I would
just I would just close before I turn
the podium over to dr. Burks for her
reports
simply to say thank you to the American
people thank you for what you've done so
far thank you for the way you've put the
health and well-being of not just family
members and and friends but but but
strangers people you didn't even know
first and we just encourage you to keep
doing what you're doing keep heating the
guidance of state and local authorities
practice good hygiene wash your hands
wear a mask wherever a state and local
authorities determined it's indicated or
wear a mask where you can't engage in
social distancing this is the role each
of us can continue to play and we're
seeing some early indications in some of
the most impacted States that Americans
are doing just that so we want to
encourage you on and tell you that we're
gonna continue to do our part and I'm
just absolutely confident just as we
proved when this pandemic was striking
so deeply in the Northeast when it was
striking in the Louisiana and in
Michigan the American people know what
needs to be done and we know we can do
it and we flattened we flattened the
curve before we slowed the spread before
and we can do it again but we've got to
all do our part and we'll do it together
with that dr. deborah birx and and then
we'll get a report from Admiral Gerrard
before we move on to other reports
Thank You mr. vice president if I could
have the first slide please and I I know
some of you do watch what I wear if I'm
wearing this specially today on this
came from the Salt River tribe I just
want a mask can be a fashion statement
and I want to thank the Salt River tribe
it was a real pleasure to be out and
speaking to individuals around the
United States about the issues that
they're facing with Cova 19 to be able
to meet with communities hospital
personnel african-american communities
Hispanic communities and our pride
tribal nations that was a privilege last
week I want to start with Arizona just
to pick up where the Vice President left
off that orange line is the number of
tests performed and the blue line is the
test positivity now this is at the level
of the state and Arizona does have
counties that were tracking very closely
obviously you know the largest one being
famous and Maricopa County but this dish
does show that the blue line which is a
five day at seven day average and thank
you to the data team for these wonderful
slides the fight the seven day average
is showing some flattening and they find
that encouraging also equally
encouraging at this point because we
know that the test positivity rate is
the first thing to increase and we're
hoping that it heralds a stability in
Arizona of at least reaching a plateau
in their curve the red line represents
the emergency room visits for any of the
kovat like symptoms and this is also an
early indicator and we find that
encouraging the next slide does show the
counties that were tracking obviously
the largest county being Maricopa County
with the largest number of infections
but clearly there's issues in Yuma and
Pima the vice president mentioned the
weekly reports that go to governor's
this is what the report looks like
source their full side pages this is
alaska's on the front page is our
interpretation of what we're seeing
relevant to their epidemic with specific
recommendations related to where we see
them as far as being in a danger zone
they are coded by yellow and red and it
follows that they see everything you're
seeing on that first report in boxes
warning boxes and then each of the
counties are represented so that they
have in one place five pages from the
White House and task force that
summarizes what we're seeing and that
goes out weekly next slide please
this looks at Florida and you can see in
the same way the red line early
suggestions of decreasing emergency room
visits for the symptoms of kovat and
some stability starting in that blue
line opening that heralds a stability
and the number of daily reported cases
we also understand that we went through
a holiday weekend and holiday weekends
can't impact data's on both end under
reporting through the weekend and then
catch-up reporting Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday after holiday weekend next
slide this shows the
counties of Florida that we are tracking
these are the top-ten counties in
Florida and you can see each of them
have a different profile I want to call
your attention to the counties that are
across the bottom there that are more
difficult to see some of those represent
Jacksonville and our other large metros
including Tampa when the governor talks
about how they were steady and low for a
long period of time after reopening this
is where that is reflected for almost
five weeks after reopening clearly there
was something that happened though and
those that were looking into across the
board because whatever happened in
Florida happened across the Sunbelt and
that all of the curves and all of the
findings are mirrored if you remember
early on in March and April we were
talking about first the what the New
York metro followed by Boston followed
by Philadelphia then Chicago and New
Orleans was with the New York metro and
so it was a series of individual curves
in this case whatever occurred occurred
almost simultaneously across the south
and so we're investigating that very
closely to really see the etiology
behind that because that can help us as
an early warning signal but also help us
and guidance to the American people of
what we're asking us to do next slide
Texas and you can see Texas is in a
similar situation with their blue line
and we're watching this very closely
across Texas next slide but I think all
of you know that there's a series of
major metros in Texas with significant
increase in cases from Houston to Dallas
to San Antonio to al Paso and McClellan
area and so the governor's get this type
of report with specific recommendations
and then finally California where you
can see next slide thank you again a
long time of stability but then this
increase in the number of test positives
and rapid increase in cases next slide
and you can see the majority of the
issue is in the Los Angeles area
although we see this through Riverside
Imperial Sacramento and now
San Francisco with increased number of
cases so I want to finish with where the
Vice President started about the
sacrifices of the American people
because in that recommendations are very
clear recommendations that when you have
a county with these types of cases we
are recommending everyone using a face
covering and I think the studies now
that have been done showing that cotton
face coverings work that does open up
the ability for us all to have
individualized face coverings that
express our personality but in addition
I think the work that these governors
have done to and ask the American people
does it stop going to bars to close the
bars to move to outdoor dining to
decrease endure any kind of indoor
gatherings again to all of the Americans
out there that are in these four states
and the states that have in the report
we're in the red zone because there's a
series of other states that we have in
that zone is really asking the American
people in those counties and in those
days in those states to not only use the
face coverings not going to bar is not
going to indoor dining but really not
gathering in homes either and decreasing
those gatherings back down to our phase
one recommendation which was ten or less
so thank you thank you mr. vice
president Thank You mr. vice president
since we're breaking on our face
coverings this was made by a small
religious community in Pennsylvania who
who were helped by the Public Health
Service and they hand sewed these for a
lot of our officers to match our
operational dress those blue uniforms so
I wear this proudly and I think of that
community every single day everybody
pitching in across America to help us
all so in terms of testing when it cover
three quick topics first one is just
where we are numerically vice president
has already said mm-hmm
we are now topping 39 million tests
across the country the states really
crushed their goal in June the state
goals was about twelve point nine
million in June CDC numbers have
finalized that at about 16 and a half
million tests for June so
congratulations to almost all of the
states who
made their goal exceeded their goal
we're doing very well right now between
six and seven hundred thousand tests per
day we did top the 700 thousand mark
last week and we're averaging about
about six hundred and twenty six hundred
and thirty thousand tests per day we
continue to ship we are ripe with swabs
and media so the states tell us what
they need we work with them to set those
goals based on their state testing plans
after technical assistance by the CDC in
my office
FEMA ships those every week now that's
along with a spur the assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
at HHS so that's sort of the overall
general view we announced yesterday what
we talked about a little bit last week
and that is federal surge sites we
opened these in three communities there
was a list of communities identified by
dr. Burks and her team that had certain
characteristics of their infection trend
but also met certain characteristics of
numerical numbers and isolation that
surge testing might have an impact over
a short period of time so our goal in
those communities is to do at least
5,000 tests per day and those are in
Baton Rouge Jacksonville and McAllen the
McAllen in Texas and we have many other
sites that we're working with again this
is a partnership with the state and
local governments to make that happen
they're up and running and testing in
all three sites Baton Rouge started
yesterday the other two sites start
today and we already have almost 6,500
appointments already made this morning
so that's going very very well the last
thing I want to talk about is Phoenix
and I don't know if we have the slides
for this I get just a little bit
concerned when I hear things in the news
like we're doing nothing for Phoenix and
the federal government hasn't been doing
anything with Phoenix because that
really is not correct and it undermines
a lot of the things that we're doing I'm
going to show you some slides I didn't
make these slides up my team this was
part of a 55 slide deck 55 slide slide
deck just on Phoenix where we understand
the demographics the health disparities
the income levels the racial and ethnic
city backgrounds we
the tests are done where the resources
are this is how we really work the
issues so first of all we're in constant
contact with Governor Ducey and his team
his state health officials are
outstanding we not only talk on the
calls but we have frequent calls and I
know dr. Redfield does this as well and
ambassador birx does this as well
number two we provide support according
to the state plans just in the last two
months we've shipped over 500,000 swabs
and media to the state to fulfill their
plans in terms of Phoenix if I can get
the first slide back please I just want
to say that yes we have lots of support
in Phoenix this is the community-based
testing locations I didn't decode this
because it's right out of my slide deck
Phoenix has three federally funded
retail sites this is paid on a per
capita basis you come up get a test
these sites not these three sites but
this overall program has tested just
under a million individuals and they're
located specifically in communities of
high social vulnerability we have three
there we also have 13 what we call 3.0
sites these are retail pharmacies that
because of our regulatory flexibility
they can do that without a federal
stipend or grant they do this just
through the insurance Medicare and
Medicaid billing system so those are 16
federal sites we have in Phoenix next
slide I don't know if there's a map to
go with that but under the leadership of
secretary azar we've really surged into
FQHCs federally qualified health centers
this is where you really want testing to
happen because these are medical homes
for those who are indigent and
underserved we have 28 FQHC sites
performing testing just in the just in
the Phoenix area right now next slide we
don't have that slide but let me talk
about we've also identified every single
testing machine in Phoenix
so there are testing machines to do tens
of thousands of tests per day and we're
sending at least a hundred thousand okay
maybe it'll come up maybe it won't but
at least a hundred thousand assays to
the Phoenix area every week so these are
all the things we're doing in the
ground that that happened on a regular
basis that we do community by community
by community now two days ago um I heard
that mayor Gallego was unhappy because
there was no federal support I heard
that on Monday on Monday morning I was
on the phone with the FEMA
representative in the afternoon it was
clear to me that Phoenix was not in tune
with all the things that the state were
doing we convened a call last night
where we had Governor Ducey's people on
the phone where we had the mayor's
people on the phone where we had various
health officials on the phone we got
everybody together understood where the
gaps are there's a surge from Arizona
State there are search and testing sites
that are state testing sites and Phoenix
that are up there and this morning
governor Ducey looked at everything
thought a surge sight would be helpful
in west Phoenix he requested that and
we're contracting that right now so I
just wanted to give you that example
because it really pains me when somebody
says the federal government isn't doing
anything when we have 41 federal sites
there we're sending supplies were
sending tests and we work with the
governor every day and if there's an
appropriate request and it's on the list
for dr. Burks
which it was we will send a surge site
and that's what we're doing we're
contracting that this afternoon thank
you thank you about your honor as we
said the focus today is unsafely
reopening our schools and as we
discussed yesterday at the White House
summit from very early in this process
the Centers for Disease Control has been
issuing guidance for schools and for
child care services in early March March
the 12th to be specific and when we
first published the 15 days to slow the
spread and encourage people to engage in
schooling from home wherever possible
from that point forward
CDC has published decision trees about
how schools can begin to develop
reopening plans and just last week
published new guidance for k-12 schools
but next week as dr. Redfield can
elaborate in a few moments they'll be
issuing five new documents that
range from preparing communities to
return to school safely to decision
making tools for parents and caregivers
and to create symptom screening
considerations as as children and
teachers return to school but as we made
clear yesterday
we'll make clear again today we're here
to help and none of the CDC's
recommendations are intended to replace
state local rules and guidance that what
we've made clear to governor's and state
and local health officials is CDC stands
ready to work with local officials as
they tailor their plan for reopening
their schools but we're all committed to
getting our kids back in the classroom
and getting them back in the classroom
this fall with that I want the Secretary
of Education to reflect on on the
efforts she's making here at the
Department of Education that will hear
from dr. Redfield and then a few wrap-up
comments from Secretary of HHS before we
go to questions thank you so much mr.
vice president thanks for hosting the
task force here today we are so grateful
to the President and to you for your
leadership on doing what's right for
students yesterday we had a really good
and important conversation at the White
House with local leaders and great
teachers and parents it was insightful
and inspiring and as mrs. pence noted
these past few months parents have worn
multiple hats they really are our unsung
heroes and I might add as the vice
president noted as are the teachers who
were often playing dual roles as parents
themselves and continuing to help their
students learn
she also said mrs. pence also said that
as we reopen businesses restaurants
theaters in our country we simply can't
leave out our schools and that is so
correct students can and must continue
to learn full-time I've been really
inspired by the innovative teachers
schools and their communities that have
kept learning going through this past
few months and they're getting ready to
do it again this fall a couple of gray
examples in Harlem and the surrounding
boroughs in New York Success Academy
moved to distance learning in one week
using multiple technology platforms
teachers there insisted on in learning
new materials right along with their
students the students were still graded
they made sure all the students had the
needed tech that they did not maybe have
at home initially miami-dade County used
existing instructional continuity plans
to make a seamless transition to
distance learning
they added interventions for students
who were struggling already before the
pandemic the International Leadership
Academy in Texas started from the
mindset that not learning wasn't an
option for any student they delivered
multilingual and special education
curriculum to all of their students
there were a number of schools and
districts across the country that did an
awesome job of transitioning this spring
and there were a lot in which I and
state school leaders were disappointed
in that they didn't figure out how to
continue to serve their students too
many of them just gave up the Center for
reinventing public education said that
only 10 percent across the board
provided any kind of real curriculum and
instruction program and as I said I've
talked to all of the state school chiefs
at least once
most of them more than once and they've
told me that while many of their
districts in their states have done well
through the past several months a number
of them they were very disappointed in
in doing next to nothing and then we see
as we talk about reopening schools there
are some creating false paradigms for
the fall and here right in our
neighborhood the DC area fair Fairfax
County which is one of the most well
funded I would call it an elite public
school system in America offered
families a so-called choice for this
fall either 0 days in school for their
students or 2 days and their spring time
attempt at distance learning was a
disaster but I have to give this as an
example because things like this cannot
happen again in the fall it would fail
America's students and it would fail
taxpayers who pay high taxes for their
education ultimately it's not a matter
of if schools should reopen it's simply
a matter of how they must fully open and
they must be fully operational and how
that happens is best left to education
and community leaders I really
appreciate something that secretary azar
reiterated yesterday at the White House
it's a Surgeon General's prescription
for health care and I'm going to repeat
it again because it bears repeating
first ask yourself what's your
individual circumstance are you or is
someone in your home vulnerable second
what's going on in your community is the
virus widespread or is it isolated and
third think about the kind of school
activity that you're talking that you're
thinking about how to how to accommodate
and deal with what needs to be in place
for things to be successful education
leaders need to examine real data for
their own states and communities and
weigh the risks local leaders in every
community need to ask these questions
and consider all the risks physical
health and safety are factors so is
mental health
so is social emotional development and
importantly very importantly so our lost
opportunities for students particularly
the most vulnerable among us and
students with disabilities the American
Academy of Pediatrics noted keeping
schools closed places children and
adolescents at considerable risk of
morbidity and in some cases mortality
the Pediatrics guidance concluded that
everyone should start with a goal of
having students physically present in
school fully open and fully operational
means that students need a full school
year or more and it's expected it will
look different depending on where you
are what's clear is that students and
their families need more options I've
talked a long time about
need to rethink education and they to
expand education options for all
students this moment really demands
action and America always was and is and
always will be a country of doers we are
confident that with grit and
determination and a measure of grace we
can and will do what's right for all the
students our nation thanks very much
thank you very much
mr. vice president first and foremost I
want to make it very very clear that the
guidance that CDC continues to put out
for schools K through 12 and higher
learning is intentional for a reopening
and keeping our schools open that it's
that's its purpose we recognize that
there's a variety of unique
circumstances for different schools in
different school districts and so we've
outlined a number of strategies that
those schools those administrators can
use to accomplish this goal safely but I
might want to make it very clear that
what is not the intent of CDC's
guidelines is to be used as a rationale
to keep schools closed we're prepared to
work with each school each jurisdiction
to help them use the different
strategies that we propose that help do
this safely so they come up with the
optimal strategy for those schools I
think it's critical and it would be
personally very disappointing to me and
I know my agency if we saw that
individuals were using these guidelines
as a rationale for not reopening our
schools I think there's a series of
different additional guidelines that we
are about to put out to help really with
the K through 12 community particularly
at the community level
helped open safely guidelines also that
come out or consideration documents for
parents and caregivers guidelines for
schools to help them understand how best
to do symptom surveillance and
characterize symptoms in the schools as
a tool and guidelines to really work at
how and the ins and outs of using
facemask in the school setting as well
as finally some guidance in to help the
schools have systems which they can
monitor their programs but I want to
close by just reiterating again the
purpose of CDC's guidances remember its
guidance it's not requirements and its
purpose is to facilitate the reopening
and the keeping open the schools in this
country because as a as the vice
president said it is critical that we
get these schools open do it safely
we're prepared to work with all the
school districts and schools to help
them facilitate their development of
their own unique plan to accomplish that
thank you thanks doctor opening up
schools is the right thing to do for our
kids so they don't fall behind
academically and also so that children
that are in need of services special
needs children children with mental
health issues nutrition needs have the
support that they receive at the schools
it's important though for parents and
for working families and we I asked
Secretary Scalia to be here from the
Department of Labor to speak about the
impact on as we put America back to work
make it possible for us to have single
parents back in the workforce it's it's
essential that we get our schools open
as well and so I wanted Secretary Scalia
and then of course Secretary of HHS to
finish our remarks before we go to
questions secretary
Thank You mr. vice president it's good
to be with you all today for reasons
that a secretary
DeVos is mentioned with the vice
president mentioned of course having our
schools open is so important to our
children's education but as the vice
president has said it's very important
as well to working men and women across
the country who need to be able to
structure their work days in a
predictable manner in the expectation
that schools will be open and their
children will be able to be in school so
that the parents in turn can have a
predictable schedule that they bring to
the workplace of course that's important
to our business places as well and in
that sense it's really critically
important to our national reopening one
study has suggested that if we closed
all our schools and daycare for just a
month just hypothetically if we if we
did that the impact on us productivity
would be on the order of 50 billion
dollars it gives you some sense of the
impact having our schools closed can
have in our national recovery I did want
to mention a couple of groups in
particular to whom this is very
important first lower wage workers one
of the great triumphs of the economy
that we have joined until the virus came
was how well lower income men and women
were doing in the workplace we as you
know had unemployment the tide of
50-year low we had record low
unemployment for African Americans
Hispanic Americans and others and and we
had rising wages wages actually rose
about 15% for lower income men and women
during the first three years of this
administration unfortunately a number of
people have observed this it's the lower
income workers who've been particularly
adversely affected by some of the
shutdowns that we've had in response to
the coronavirus unemployment among the
lower income workers has been a higher
than for other populations and therefore
for them having schools reopen so that
they can themselves have predictable
schedules be able to return to the
workplace
is going to be very important they hold
jobs that are less likely to be jobs by
which you can tell commute I think many
of us know that even telecommuting there
are burdens being placed on mothers
fathers who are getting up a little bit
earlier or staying up a lot later to get
work done to plan around caring for
their children in the interim but for
lower income men and women that option
often it's not even available and then
second let me comment briefly on working
women who studies show and I think
experience many of us reflects that it's
women in the household who quite often
bear the larger burden when it comes to
caring for children studies show this
and and and again prior to Cove another
great success of the economy were
enjoying was the employment rate for
women the unemployment rate for women
was actually lower than for men right
before the virus came but unfortunately
and this is a statistic we've been
tracking we see that the unemployment
rate for women now is is higher than it
is for men now we made great progress in
June the vice president mentioned the
extraordinary jobs report we've put
seven and a half million Americans back
to work in just two months and the
unemployment wait rate for women dropped
nearly three percent in June but still
we have important work to do and we know
that working women will have a harder
time getting back to the workplace they
continue to cite childcare at a much
higher rate than men do is a reason that
they're not able to work and so for them
to reopen in our schools will be very
important
look just to wrap up in such an
important sense the pace and structure
of our national life is built around the
expectation that our young people will
be in school in in person during the
school year that's so important for them
but it's also vitally important for
their parents and in that sense so
critical to this reopening that is
proceeding very well economically but to
keep going we need our schools open in
the fall
thank you very much well thank you very
much mr. vice-president for your
leadership of the presidents all of
America approach to combating the virus
and for the focus that you're now
putting on getting our kids safely back
to school from HHS's perspective
reopening school safely may be the
single most important thing that we can
do to support healthy families during
this pandemic all decisions about
undertaking activities during kovat 19
have to look at risk as a continuum not
a binary question States and school
districts can think about the same
things that we urge individuals to think
about as Secretary DeVos noted our
Surgeon General has come out with his
prescription for health ask yourself
three critical questions where are you
is there significant community
transmission of the virus in your area
whom are we talking about children are
much less much less susceptible to
severe outcomes from the virus than
adults and what activities are we
looking at there are more and less risky
activities for schools like keeping kids
in the same classroom versus changing
classes avoiding large gatherings and
doing activities outside whenever
possible reopening schools comes with
some risk but there are risks to keeping
kids at home too at home kids aren't
benefiting from social stimulation they
may be falling behind and learning they
may be more vulnerable to abuse that
goes unreported by the mandatory
reporters in our school system they may
not be getting special services they may
need they may not be getting the
nutrition that they get at school and it
may be difficult for parents to get back
to work as Secretary Scalia noted this
issue like so many considerations around
safely reopening isn't about health
versus the economy but about health
versus health all of this is why the
American Academy of Pediatrics has
strongly recommended beginning with the
goal of having students physically
present in school
this goal is the right way to use the
extensive guidance that CDC has put out
to help each state and school district
think through a safe reopening last week
we've put out guidance around testing
for K through 12 schools this guidance
like our guidance for colleges and
universities offers recommendations for
how and when students teachers and staff
should be tested while CDC does not make
a recommendation in favor of universal
testing it's a perfectly appropriate
surveillance technique where the
capacity exists and capacity is growing
all the time we've talked with colleges
and universities that are able to use
their research lab capacity with pooling
of multiple samples to test their whole
student bodies and staff frequently
thanks to regulatory flexibility that
CMS and the FDA have provided many of
the leaders we heard from yesterday at
the White House school reopening summit
are doing testing before returning to
school and then Sentinel surveillance on
top of that the measures we recommend
universally like keeping a distance
wearing a face covering and frequent
hand-washing are effective and can be
applied in the college or the K through
12 setting we put out the CDC guidance
to enable and support States and school
districts in reopening safely we want
them to use the tools available to
reduce risk and we'll be putting out
more guidance on how schools can use
each of these tools such as face
coverings on top of that I will
reiterate that our set of tools is
expanding all of the time just yesterday
we signed a new agreement with Regeneron
to provide nearly half a billion dollars
in support for a promising therapeutic
all the way to manufacturing hundreds of
thousands of doses for the American
people
the initial doses pending approval would
be available as soon as the end of this
summer or early fall that is the first
of a number of therapeutic agreements
that we will do under the president's
operation warp-speed initiative
promising therapeutics are already being
administered every day by our heroic
health care workers I want to thank
these heroes who continue to put
themselves at risk caring for those
suffering from the virus
we know many frontline workers have
gotten sick and we know some have given
their lives including some of my
employees in the Indian Health Service
and America is deeply grateful it is
because we are making progress against
the virus and learning more about it
every day that we can talk about how to
bring America's kids and teachers back
to school safely we have the tools to do
it and it has to be a top priority so
thank you to President Trump and the
vice president for putting such a focus
on this very important aspect of our
road to recovery thank you and the
president's call to reopen schools is
there a situation in some states as a
health situation doesn't allow for this
where you would be supportive of some
states continuing distance learning and
we now see the president threatening to
cut off funding for schools is that a
serious threat and what would that look
like well the principle behind our
approach to this coronavirus pandemic
has been to provide federal support as
as states managed their own response and
what I can tell you is in the weekly
reports that we provide governor's we're
down to the county level in terms of
where the new cases are where the
positivity lies and I think we would
account for the fact that while we hope
we hope every school in America is able
to open this fall there may be some
states and local communities that that
given cases or positivity and that
community may adjust to either a certain
set of days or certain limitations and
will be very respectful of that what the
president's made clear though is that we
think it's absolutely imperative that
every state and territory in this
country make make steps and take steps
rather to get kids back in the classroom
to the fullest extent possible
we really believe that that every state
and has the ability to do that but for
those individual communities that may be
seeing outbreaks we'll work with them
give them the guidance and the support
to be able to implement the policies
that they deem are most appropriate our
our mission here is to safely reopen our
schools and as you've heard from all of
these members of our task force's it's
not just about kids learning and not
falling behind academically it's about
all the vital services that children
receive at our schools it's about
working families it's about opening up
America again
and so we'll continue to drive on that
on your second point I would tell you
that at this point I think 90% of
education funding comes from the states
roughly 10% depending on States budgets
come from the federal government and as
we work with Congress on the next round
of state support we're going to be
looking for ways to give States a strong
incentive and encouragement to get kids
back to school please the president
tweeted this morning that he disagrees
with the CDC's very tough and expensive
guidelines for reopening schools do you
also disagree with those guidelines and
are you concerned that you may be
putting the health of students and
teachers at risk by trying to meet the
president's demand to reopen well the
president I spoke about that this
morning and I think what you will see in
the coming days what you heard from dr.
Redfield yesterday at the summit and
again today is very consistent with the
president's objective and the concerns
these raised we don't want the guidance
from CDC to be a reason why schools
don't open we want to partner with
States with local education officials
with governor's with local health
officials to find a way to meet their
needs to open up and I think the
president's statement this morning was
simply reflective of the
desire and but we remain very confident
that as we continue to provide resources
we're seeing not just not just K through
12 education I mean all 47 states and
two territories have already published
plans and guidance for reopening their
schools and we reiterated to the
governor's earlier this week and again
at the summit yesterday that we're
really here to partner with them to
achieve that I think what the president
was saying this morning is that if there
are aspects of the CDC's recommendations
that are prescriptive or that serve to
as a as a barrier to kids getting back
to school we want we want governors and
and local officials and education
leaders to know that we're here to work
with them to support the measures
they're putting into place but I I I
think every American every American
knows that we can safely reopen our
schools and we just want we want we want
to we want as the president said this
morning to make sure that what we're
doing doesn't stand in the way of doing
that go ahead just to follow up when
we're talking about the health of
children though shouldn't the guidance
be tough and should no expense be spared
well I'm gonna ask Bob Redfield to speak
to that and one of the things that we we
have seen and I tell you as a parent as
much as your vice president in the head
of this task force I've been I've been
grateful for it is that that apart from
having an underlying health condition
children do not appear to be susceptible
to serious illness from the coronavirus
dr. Burton speak to that statistically
on a global basis and that's been a
blessing for Americans and American
families and and so as this secretaries
are just said we know that the risk of
serious illness to children is very low
and there are measures we can put into
place to make sure that we don't we
don't see the spread of the virus or
outbreaks in individual schools by
having children learn
a single classroom or learn outside as
often as possible not go into larger
settings and this is all the kind of
guidance that the CDC is putting forward
but but I'm gonna let Bob Redfield speak
to that because we we really do believe
that we can open these schools safely
given this the what we've seen in terms
of outcomes among children and and also
the kind of measures that we think we
can put into effect to to prevent the
spread Thank You mr. vice president I
think it's really important to be clear
that our recommendations to open these
schools are really based on the sound
public health and safety and health of
children I think you heard already from
some of the speakers there's substantial
health consequences that we've seen as a
consequence of schools being closed
whether it's access to mental health
services or its access to nutrition
clearly we know a lot and I think it's
important that we don't react
emotionally but we act based on data
clearly the ability of this virus to
cause significant illness in children is
very very very very limited we know of
the post immune inflammatory disease
that you've heard about but it's very
rare but in general this virus does not
cause significant illness and children
secondly and I think it's important
unlike influenza where one of our
biggest concerns is we've been able to
show that it's really schools and
children that become the instrument of
transmission throughout our community
with influenza we really don't have
evidence that children are driving the
transmission cycle of this the most
important thing as we reopen schools and
as I mentioned before we're prepared to
work with every school and every school
district to help them find the right
mixture of strategies for them to do
this safely
our recommendations are not requirements
and they're not meant to be prescriptive
we have lots of different options on how
the schools can put it together well we
do want to reiterate as we reopen
schools is to remember the importance of
protecting the vulnerable that we will
be strong on it's important to limit the
ability of individuals with significant
comorbidities individuals that happen to
be elderly with comorbidities we want to
limit those individuals their
interactions in general and society
independent of schools thanks Bob let me
say just also in response to your
question I would recommend that every
American reviewed the statement issued
by the American Academy of Pediatrics
that that releases an important report
indicating that there are real physical
and mental cause for children to be
deprived of of an in classroom setting
ranges from nutrition to children that
have special needs we we heard from dr.
McCants Katz that some 7 million
children in America deal with mental
health issues in the services and the
counseling they receive they received at
their schools and so we want to put the
health and well-being of our kids first
and given the fact that children as dr.
Redfield said again do not appear to be
susceptible to serious outcomes from the
coronavirus we want to put their the
totality of their health and their
well-being forward and that all tells us
it tells the president tells this
taskforce that means we need to get our
kids back to school
please reticulated the problem the
myriad risks that students face if they
stay out of school come to fall but
what's the plan what's the
administration's specific plan in terms
of increased testing contact tracing
increased PPE if it's needed to support
these schools as you well know schools
weren't built for students to socially
distance they were built to pack in as
many kids as humanly possible which is
one of the reasons why school districts
like Fairfax Virginia this called
to New York and Texas they have moved to
this hybrid approach some virtual
learning some in-person learning so
what's what's the plan and I have a
question for dr. Burks about kids in
covent if I may well the plan is
continued to do what we have done from
the very beginning as you heard again
this morning we're we're leav 39 million
tests that have been performed all
across this country your merger are
described the extraordinary commitment
in just one community alone and what
we've conveyed to governor's is whatever
support they need to get kids back to
school we're going to make sure that
they have we're going to make sure that
they have the testing resources we're
currently educating States on the
possibility and working with commercial
labs and the possibility of what's
called pooling so that literally there
could be one test run on say ten samples
and and there are there are particular
universities that already have built
into their plans the idea of testing all
of their students at the beginning of
the academic year and then doing
surveillance testing but we made it very
clear whether it's testing whether it's
personal protective equipment or other
resources that we stand ready to provide
those resources to the states and and we
reiterated that once again to the
governor's but the good news is because
of the historic mobilization that
President Trump initiated we literally
have hundreds of millions of supplies of
personal protective equipment 59,000
ventilators in the strategic national
stockpile testing is scaling all across
America and we know that come to school
year we'll be ready to meet those needs
question doctor what's the infection
rate among children and what's the very
latest in terms of that you know in
terms of how the virus presents in
children how children transmit the virus
to older adults nearly a third of
teachers across this country or age 50
and older and what's the best practice
in terms of testing children I've never
heard of a case where a school child is
tested for Kovan 19 those are all good
questions and I think it really comes to
the
evidence base of what do we have as far
as testing and children so if you look
across all of the tests that we've done
and whether we when we have the age the
portion that is then the lowest tested
portion is the under 10 year-olds so
we're putting into place other ways to
get testing results from them and
looking at antibody in that discarded
samples and try to fairly figure this
out because parents have really done an
amazing job of protecting their children
I think Americans have done a great job
in keeping infection rates low in
children under the sheltering time and
keeping infection rates right now in
this new cases originally I think we saw
great protection of people with
comorbidities we are worried now that as
cases spread that it's getting to the
older parents and the grandparents and I
call on again every multi-generational
household get tested and protect those
in the household and we do know that
there are children with vulnerabilities
and certainly within the CDC plan and
Department of Education it's protecting
those children also from getting exposed
to the virus because we do know there
are children with comorbidities we know
that their children in America with
cancer and getting undergoing
chemotherapy but when you ask that
question the parents have so protected
their children and remember early on we
said test if you have symptoms and now
we know that if you're under 18 the
majority of you don't have symptoms and
so really figuring out and there's
universities working around the country
on a saliva test so be easy easier for
children to put saliva in a tube just
basically what we call spitting in a
tube are spitting through a straw into a
tube and looking at that kind of
innovation and testing and what Admiral
girar has been working on very hard is
this antigen based testing and getting
that equipment into both vulnerable
areas like nursing homes assisted living
and other places but also considering
how a school district could use that
would make it much easier to test and to
use saliva so all of those are being
worked on and it's why we've been
pushing on the antigen test I know you
heard me talk about that in April
we're pushing on that because we think
it is important for testing of students
and testing and universities but we have
the our data is skewed originally to
people with symptoms and then skewed to
adults over 18 and so we are looking
very closely into that category by using
our antibody tests I think the
vice-president covered that incredibly
well we know that mortality rate in
under twenty five from the CDC data is
less than 0.1% and so that has been
holding but until we know how many have
been infected we have no evidence that
there is significant mortality in
children without coexisting diseases and
that's what we're looking for right now
is to really make sure we've unter
overturned every Rock and understand
that in deep detail we all know the CDC
guidelines are not requirements their
advice and this the president when he
calls it too tough or impractical making
it easier for Americans and for school
officials to ignore that advice I I have
every confidence that governors and
state education officials and local
health officials are going to implement
the policies that they think are in the
best interest of children and families
and I think the president's sentiment
this morning I think is is shared widely
by the American people and certainly by
members of this task force we we want to
make it very clear that excuse me the
guidance that were issuing is is not to
supplant the laws the rules the
regulation of the decisions at the state
level it's meant to create essentially a
range of options and what we made clear
to governor's on the governor's call
this week specifically was that we are
prepared at the CDC to sit down with
state officials and to work through
their plan and
and be able to advise and and dialogue
with them about about the best way
forward but I I must tell you that in
this role over the last four months I
I've been impressed by governors in both
political parties and health officials
in all of our state's and our
territories with the way they put the
health of their people first and but I
must also say that I have a great sense
talking to governor's and a great sense
this is a some of the American people
want to see happen and governors they're
hearing that they know that and that's
why you have 47 states that have already
issued plans or guidelines and we're
going to work with them to make those a
reality okay can you explain why the
president is threaded threatening to cut
funding from schools at a time when
educators are saying they need more so
they can safely reopen Katelyn first and
foremost it's what you heard from the
president is just a determination to
provide the kind of leadership from the
federal level it says that we're going
to get our kids back to school because
that's where they belong and and we know
based upon what what our best health
officials tell us that we can do that in
a safe and in a responsible way
but to be clear the the current cares
Act provided thirteen point three
billion dollars to support education
efforts in States in the midst of the
pandemic we're going to work with
Congress we expect there'll be
additional support there but the
president is just very serious for all
the reasons that we discussed today he
believes and we believe it's absolutely
essential for our children's academic
development and and for their social and
emotional and health and nutrition needs
to be back in the classroom and and
we're going to provide the leadership
from the federal level to do that that
being said I will tell you I sense a
great desire
among governor's around the country to
find a way forward
and we've made it very clear to them
that we're going to partner with them
providing them with the resources to
impact that and also the supplies local
decision so shouldn't it be up to them
to decide if they can safely reopen and
not the president saying he's going to
pressure them to do so well I look we're
going to respect those unique
communities that may have challenges
that have rising cases or rising
positivity and but I think you look at
the nation as a whole I think what the
President of the United States has made
clear as he thinks as we reopen America
we need to reopen America schools it's
just as the president said earlier this
pandemic that he wanted to get our
places of worship back open again I
think what you're seeing president
provide is leadership and what we're
providing from the White House
coronavirus task force is partnership
with the governors and with state health
officials because we just got to get we
got to get our kids back I I have to
tell you the the best expert I know on
this topic is my wife Karen and she
spoke at the summit yesterday very
compellingly about how a lot of our kids
are hurting out there they're struggling
with loneliness with social isolation
the American Academy of Pediatrics spoke
about that a very forceful statement
from pediatricians across the country
that said we got to get our kids back
into school and so what you're what
you're going to see Caitlyn is the
president going to continue to provide
leadership I expect as the debate in
Congress goes forward about additional
resources we're going to look to build
in incentives for States to go forward
but president's made it clear and I
think most parents in America would
agree with him that we got to get our
kids back to school and we got to get
them back into the classroom and we can
do it in a safe in a responsible way
that's okay the guidance that the CDC
has put out it sounds like you think it
is in the best interest of students and
ways to safely reopen schools so far so
are you going to change that guidance
because the president said that he does
not like it well I think I just want to
reiterate we're going to continue to
work with local states and jurisdictions
I think the guidance that we've put out
gives a series of different strategies
for them to consider what is the most
appropriate in their unique situation to
adopt again and I want to come back to
the goal and the goal of this is to get
the schools reopened
I did mention and I want to reiterate
that goal is just not a goal to reopen
schools that's the goal because we
believe that's in the best public health
interest of the students for the reasons
you've heard we will continue to develop
and evolve our guidance to meet the
needs of the schools and the states that
we continue to provide that assistance
to I'm sorry I can't hear your question
the guidance the guidance recommends
that that schools have social distancing
of students six feet apart and that's
why these schools are adopting these
hybrid models is because they don't feel
they can keep students six feet apart
within their within their building so
I'm just wondering if that particular
part of the guidance is something you're
rethinking or do you support that social
distancing inside schools because that's
where schools I think are having trouble
well the president said today we just
don't want the guidance to be too tough
and that's the reason why next week
CDC is going to be issuing a new set of
tools five different documents that are
be giving even more clarity on the
guidance going forward but we know each
school system you know has unique
capabilities different facilities and
well what parents around the country
should know is that we're here to help
we're here to work with their governor's
with their local education officials to
get our kids back to school I mean the
truth of the matter is that as we as we
reopen America we've got a we got to
reopen our schools for the well-being of
our kids for their academic advancement
for working families but also as you've
heard again today for to continue the
momentum that we see in this economy
that we saw last week with nearly 5
million jobs created and I want to
promise the American people we're going
to stay focused at this task force on
saving lives meeting the needs of our
state and our health care workers on
protecting the vulnerable and reopening
America's economy schools work and
worship so thank you all very much
we'll talk to you in a few days
you